هذع تونس ماهي واحد وقت حبين
علقنا على المسار الثوري في تونس اما خلال
المدونين من خلال شخصياتهم خلال من خلال
النظال بعهم اليوم مش نحكي على الثوره
الفيلم يحكي على المدونين هذوما وعلى
الشباب التونسي هذاك اسمه الجيل الملعون
بالانجليز ولا بالفرنسي جينراسيون موديت
خاطر احنا الجيل سمنا جيل بن علي احنا
ولاد عمار وهو عمار كان كنا نطلق اسم عمار
على اللي يعمل في الحجب في تونس وهو باش
ما نقولو بن علي دك سميناه عمار الانسان
الجاهل اللي ما يعرف حت شي معناها يعرف
كان يحجب اكها معناها تحركوا تحركوا انقب
الدنيا يا ابو قلب عملنا ريفولوسيون ب
التسميه عمار هو هذا شخصيا هو في الحقيقه
بن علي بن علي في الحجب بن علي الحجب بن
علي جاب الحجب لتونس معهو اللي جابنا كنا
الجيل عشنا في مرحله 23 سنه اللي حكم فيها
بن علي قبل كانوا ابائنا كانوا يقول انت
جيل معنا بتعبر عليه اقل مثقفين اقل منا
وقرين اقل منا مستوى التعليمي طاح في تونس
معناها مقارنه بالاجيال السابقه باجيل
بيبه
دخلوك في السيستم جما السيم الصحافه
البديله على
الانترنت في تونس نقرا موقع الكتروني عندي
اصدق من اني نقرا واحد كاتب
ف
[موسيقى]
الفينوم
ن